y
[Música]
en medio de protestas y el rechazo
internacional del gobierno militar de
mianmar en el poder tras el golpe de
estado ordenó a las compañías de
telecomunicaciones el bloqueo de
facebook en medio de campañas de
desobediencia civil y de protestas en la
segunda ciudad más grande del país por
su parte el secretario general de la onu
afirmó que el organismo ejercerá toda la
presión posible para que el golpe
fracase
la bancada demócrata de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu votará este
jueves para que la congresista
republicana marjorie taylor greene sea
removida de sus asignaciones en los
comités en los que participa esto
después de que el líder de la bancada
republicana se rehúsa a imponer castigos
contra ella güines señalada de promover
teorías conspirativas e incluso actos de
violencia contra políticos demócratas
se cumplen seis meses de la explosión
que devastó el puerto de beirut la
capital de líbano los ciudadanos
consideran que no se ha hecho justicia y
el empeoramiento de las condiciones de
vida además de rechazo a las medidas del
confinamiento por la pandemia ha
generado más protestas tenemos el
reporte
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 cerrado blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos en mianmar donde las
protestas continúan cuatro días después
de que el golpe militar destituyera y
detuviera a la líder democráticamente
elegida han shan su chip y sustituyera
por una junta militar los gobernantes
militares en mianmar han bloqueado el
acceso a facebook que se había
convertido en un punto de encuentro
clave para la oposición tras estos
hechos el secretario general de la onu
antonio guterres prometió movilizar una
campaña de presión internacional para
que el golpe militar fracase veamos el
siguiente informe
estos manifestantes en las calles de la
segunda ciudad de mianmar mandalay
quizás sean sólo unos pocos pero la
alarma por el abrupto cambio de
liderazgo en el país es generalizada
muchos temen que cualquier manifestación
pueda ser reprimida por los militares
estamos protestando de forma no violenta
contra el golpe de estado no podemos
aceptar el golpe militar y el uso del
peor ni las armas
[Música]
este es el sonido de la tambaleante
democracia de mianmar
con cacerolazos por segunda noche
consecutiva los manifestantes
denunciaron el golpe militar en un
intento para frenar las protestas la
junta interrumpió temporalmente el
acceso a internet y bloqueó facebook que
los manifestantes utilizan para
organizarse para saltarse las
restricciones la aplicación de
mensajería por bluetooth wi-fi ha sido
descargada más de un millón de veces en
jean marc por otra parte los médicos de
varios hospitales estatales como este de
jan wijn se niegan a trabajar para el
nuevo gobierno y dicen que sólo
realizarán tratamientos de urgencia
estos lazos rojos simbolizan su apoyo al
que debería ser el actual partido
gobernante y la liga nacional para la
democracia
no quiero que mis hijos crezcan bajo el
régimen militar quiero ser una buena
madre una ciudadana responsable y
también una buena doctora
[Música]
el lunes los militares derrocaron y
arrestaron a la líder democráticamente
elegida a un sandwich y desde entonces
fueron presentados cargos en su contra
por supuestamente violar las leyes de
importación y exportación del país
vamos ahora a eeuu donde los demócratas
en la cámara de representantes votarán
este jueves para que la congresista
mario little del green sea removida de
sus funciones en los comités de
educación trabajo y de presupuesto esto
después de tellier de la bancada
republicana en la cámara baja- kevin
mccarthy se negara a imponer castigos
contra green señalada promover teorías
conspirativas de que van a denunciar un
supuesto fraude electoral en los
comicios del 3 de noviembre e incluso
actos de violencia contra políticos
demócratas tampoco se tomaron medidas
contra el número 3 de la bancada
republicana al isstey ni quien ha sido
presionada tras haber votado a favor de
un segundo impeachment contrato donald
trump esto dijo que misma parte sobre
los polémicos comentarios green
denunció a todos esos comentarios que se
hicieran todos y también ella vino a la
reunión y lo denunciaron igualmente ella
dijo que se equivocó y nada de las cosas
que ella ha dicho las ha dicho desde un
integrante del congreso y los votantes
decidieron que ella podía venir aquí y
servir y para entender un poco lo que
pasa dentro del partido republicano en
eeuu quiero saludar en este momento a
robert matthews analista político y
asesoró sobre la política interior y
exterior de eeuu y normativos que hace
por estar aquí con nosotros en france24
le pregunto qué ha implicado la llegada
de mario liz taylor greene al congreso
estadounidense y qué significado tendría
una eventual prohibición para que
participe en los comités de la cámara
baja donde ella está incluida
bueno el caso es casi único ahora en
cuanto al congreso decidiendo de
proceder con la resolución 72 de remover
o quitar
madrid- el green de los comités si el
partido republicano no lo lo lo hace
antes por ejemplo hoy y parece que no lo
va a hacer el partido está dividido en
dos a las principales 1 moderada del
partido tradicional que es ahora una
minoría del partido hay que reconocer
que todavía 50% de los republicanos y
147 de los congresistas republicanos no
creen en la legitimidad de la elección
de iovine
ahora usted habla de una división del
partido republicano pero volvamos un
poco a lo que dicen ellos porque tras no
imponer castigos ni contra mayorista el
derbi ni contra eliceche ni los
republicanos aseguran que esto demuestra
una unidad en el partido usted decía que
está dividido que radiografía más
profunda hace el partido republicano
estadounidense
si ésta está apostando mejor digo ahora
de incluir las dos alas para ganar las
elecciones vía anuales en 22 que es
también históricamente el caso de que el
partido en la oposición gana en el
segundo
ronda de elecciones congresistas en 22
entonces eso es una apuesta vamos a ver
si sale porque está en esa propuesta
naturalmente la idea de que el
extremismo ha que ha llegado al partido
los ultraderechistas son parte del
partido y arriesgando que la varios
sectores del país que no está de que
están de acuerdo que han votado en el
pasado republicano va a rechazar ese ala
extremista ahora en cierto sentido
personificado por
por taylor greene
señor más dios gracias por acompañarnos
y por estar con nosotros en france 24
feliz resto de mañana nosotros
continuamos con más información acá en
el estudio porque más de 140 mil
chilenos fueron vacunados contra el kobe
19 en la primera jornada de inoculación
masiva con la vacuna desarrollada por el
laboratorio chino sinovac las
autoridades habilitaron más de 1.400
centros en todo el país
este plan de inmunización pretende
alcanzar en marzo los cinco millones de
vacunados y comenzó con personas mayores
de 90 años con esta cifra chile ya
superó los 209 mil 500 vacunados desde
que empezó a administrar a su personal
sanitario el 24 de diciembre luego ya
haber recibido un primer lote del
laboratorio pzifer bayón take
esta domingo 7 de febrero ecuador elegir
a un nuevo presidente unos comicios a la
sombra del recuerdo del ex presidente
rafael correa ahora exiliado en bélgica
entre 16 candidatos andrés zarautz y
guillermo lazo lidera en la intención de
voto en el país andino pero un programa
de recuperación económica del candidato
graus ha concentrado el debate electoral
nuestro corresponsal gustavo ortega con
más información desde la capital
ecuatoriana
'ecuador revive la nostalgia en las
calles antes de las elecciones generales
del 7 de febrero el recuerdo de rafael
correa- aún está presente en algunos
ciudadanos que clavan la vuelta al
socialismo
andrés ser aus representa la tendencia
afín al expresidente correa un
economista de 35 años que implante a un
programa de ayuda social con la entrega
de mil dólares a un millón de familias
ecuatorianas ante la pérdida del 40% de
los ingresos a causa de la pandemia aquí
vamos a defender
una crisis económica sin precedente de
la que culpan al actual presidente lenin
moreno y demandan volver al viejo modelo
político como él
porque se trabaja con el señor
que se ha asesorado por el señor correa
porque si fue un señor hay muchas
personas que están tratando de después
de esta pandemia recuperar lo que es el
comercio entonces sí sería muy bueno que
les ayude para así poder fomentar otra
vez lo que es su capital su ingreso para
seguir pues en el día a día
del otro lado de ir a hacer al programa
social de andrés araus es cuestionado
por su principal contendor el candidato
de derecha y banquero guillermo lasso es
una propuesta en el aire hueca con
dinero que no le pertenece al gobierno
ese dinero del banco central le
pertenece a los depositantes de la banca
a las a los municipios a las prefecturas
y al sistema de seguridad social del
ecuador por lo tanto ese no es un dinero
de propiedad del gobierno el actual
presidente del inh moreno también se
presentó como partidario de rafael
correa antes de su giro político
que con andrés araos aseguran no
repetirán
y este 4 de febrero se cumplen seis
meses de la explosión que devastó el
puerto de beirut dejando más de 200
muertos y miles de heridos los
ciudadanos que denuncian un
empeoramiento de las condiciones de vida
y se enfrentan a las medidas de
confinamiento estiman que todavía no se
ha hecho justicia por lo ocurrido en
agosto del año 2020 por eso salen de
nuevo a protestar desde las calles de
beirut nuestra corresponsal es del
bonito con todos los detalles
las autoridades libanesas prometieron
que en cinco días se esclarecerán los
hechos de la investigación por la
explosión del puerto de beirut del 4 de
agosto que acabó con la vida de 200
personas y destrozó media ciudad pero
seis meses después los libaneses se
siguen preguntando qué es lo que ocurrió
y ninguno de los responsables ha rendido
cuentas ante la justicia es por eso que
hoy cientos de libaneses han venido aquí
al palacio de justicia no solamente en
la ciudad de beirut sino también en
trípoli y en sidón en solidaridad con
los familiares de las víctimas y para
exigir justicia la investigación está
suspendida desde el pasado 17 de
diciembre después de que varios ex
ministros pidieran la suspensión del
juez encargado de los casos para dif
aguas aguas acusó al primer ministro en
funciones
hasan diab y a tres miembros de su
gabinete
de acto de negligencia ya que conocían
la existencia de las 3.750 toneladas de
nitrato de amonio guardadas en el hangar
número 14 del puerto de beirut pero el
primer ministro no ha comparecido ante
el tribunal apelando su inmunidad
y en deportes el australian open debería
comenzar según lo programado aunque las
autoridades dicen que no hay garantías
esto después de que más de 500 personas
entre jugadores y demás acreditados
fueran sometidos a aislamiento tras la
confirmación de un caso positivo de kobe
19 los jugadores tendrán que aislarse
hasta que se les practique pruebas que
confirmen que no están contagiados
veamos
un caso positivo por coronavirus envió a
las grandes estrellas del tenis de nuevo
a aislamiento unas 520 personas entre
jugadores y demás acreditados para el
australian open tendrán que someterse a
pruebas después de que un caso positivo
fuera detectado en un trabajador del
hotel grand hyatt todos los partidos en
los eventos previos fueron suspendidos
para este jueves sin embargo el riesgo
es bajo
el último caso en salir del hotel de
salud fue el día 22 pasaron cerca de 14
días desde ese momento así que si hubo
alguna exposición estarían llegando a
ese periodo ahora así que pensamos que
el riesgo es relativamente bajo así que
es por esto que estamos haciendo pruebas
para estar seguros pero de nuevo es por
precaución
aunque los organizadores dicen que no
hay garantías creen que el primer gran
slam del año que debe comenzar el lunes
podrá realizarse
estamos absolutamente confiados de que
el abierto de australia se va a realizar
sabemos que tuvimos un periodo que hemos
tenido que superar con esos 507
jugadores y su personal son 160
jugadores de hecho que necesitan una
prueba y contamos plenamente con que la
posibilidad es muy baja que no habrá
ningún problema esperamos que todos
ellos de negativo y luego continuaremos
con el juego mañana como lo planeamos
originalmente si los jugadores dan
negativo podrán retomar la competición
el estado cde del grand slam ha sufrido
uno de los cierres más grandes y duros
del mundo para contener el nuevo
coronavirus y el caso del miércoles fue
el primero adquirido localmente en el
estado en casi un mes
así las cosas entonces vamos a ver si se
pueden jugar estos este grand slam
o no hasta que el informativo france24
continué con nosotros para más
actualizaciones de noticias feliz día
[Música]
france24 en español sigue crecía